hey guys welcome to day three of our
cabin trip we're really excited because
beau is on his way if you don't know who
beau is its brianne's new little puppy
and it is the cutest thing ever
he is about to arrive I cannot wait I
even cleaned up a little some stuff on
the floor we don't want puppy to eat it
also the Steelers are playing but Brian
forgot his Steeler Jersey is it okay er
it's okay bring the puppy just bring him
here now look would you like me to guys
we're obsessed with this dog like
obsessed I can't even stand it I need go
potty
come here oh why didn't you the face cuz
you're so excited
Oh mommy's calling oh no oh no oh
goodness
you gotta ball you can have it it's for
you just kidding okay guys boat he's
like the sweetest little dog but he like
me he sleeps like he's out and look at
him like he's he's alive and well we
took him to the vet he's perfectly
healthy but he doesn't know he said
asleep he does not wake up there's just
little Cajun lad gonna get it like he
does not wake up oh he's kickin okay
like what do I do with him oh do be just
fine back on the ice we just put it out
like look at him think he's so so cute
like I love this puppy so much good
night papa he knows his normal puppy
behavior hmm please wake up and play
Nokes he's gonna wake up at 3:00 a.m.
he's real tired he's tuckered out you
need a busy day they didn't ever gonna
let you sleep now why not so we're
packing to go home I'm on puppy
babysitting duty hold jeez he just like
runs
under your feet and like you can't even
see him because he's such a such a
little turd
there's Nintendo DS what do you think
about that what do you think about Smash
Brothers okay well these are all things
you can't have
I've got a pack so you've got to do
something you pee me so mad at you no
long right on DS oh my no we can't have
those let go no yeah but these are my
underwear Victoria's Secret special you
cannot wear those holy crap I will never
I don't think I'll be able to do this
this is my no it's my nice shirt no come
on
yeah well play with this this isn't a
toy that you can play with come on
yeah we're going for our last walk
before we head home and Beau is now
leash training because leash not leaf he
is leash training cuz he just likes to
run free but he can't do that I'm bad at
telling him no I will tell him no no
let's go
oh no no no that's mulch don't eat that
you guys are gonna miss Bo when we go
back to to California I'm gonna miss him
he's so cute he's really just the cutest
phone make sure you guys follow me on
snapchat there's a bunch of really great
Bo pics but they may be gone by the time
I post this and snapchat only lasts for
24 hours hello okay I just want to say
goodbye just want to say goodbye
look you're so excited to be home you
haven't been home in a day hmm
okay bo tell everyone on the Internet by
nope don't I okay okay
[Music]